foreign
[Applause]
before we got here y'all know each other
you've known each other for like years
for years and years and Rob and Brian's
wife is one of my best friends and she
was a bridesmaid at our wedding and we
were at their wedding yeah and that's
like a learning time ago that's like for
us it's almost 35 and for you 34 there
yeah exactly just one of your part oh my
gosh so wait do you all have y'all ever
had like I mean in that I haven't seen
him since yeah I imagine you've had a
game Nutter dinner or some kind of fun
thing y'all done together right well
we've had many fun things that we've
done together but there is a really fun
thing that we've done and sometimes we
have a dinner at our party at our house
called Sing for your supper party and we
tell people that they have to come and
they have to sing and you don't have to
be a singer you can be anything in the
business but you have to come you have
to bring a sing song or you get no
dinner and what do you mean you don't to
be a singer so they don't have to sing
no like if let's say sing they have to
sing but you don't have to be a
professional to do it as a matter of
fact it's better if you're not a
professional oh my God this is like my
best friend's wedding when Cameron Diaz
does the karaoke just like that but you
know my pianist comes and he can play
anything and people just show up with
their songs and there have been many
times that people
um really impress you oh my God in more
ways than one yes
they dive deeper or they really commit
exactly
exactly well I wanted the dinner party
the ones really commit yes
[Music]
[Applause]